Now to receive these callbacks. We first go back to the physics engine class
and add a nice wrapper function that allows us to set some of the callback
functions for box2D. In general Box2D allows you to get callbacks during
multiple phases of collision. We have a begin contact, which occurs when things
are touching, but the collision calculated hasn't done yet. End contact when
the contact analysis is over, and post solve which is called once the physics
collisions have occurred. For our purposes, we need to find a new function in
the physics engine that allows the engine to pass in customs callbacks, to be
executed when anyone of these phases occurs. This code is fairly simple
although deep. We take in an object that contains callbacks we're looking for
and define logic that will issue a callback to those functions, once the engine
hits that phase. So, for instance, we assume that is the callbacks.PostSolve
method exists, then we define the PostSolve method on our listener as a
function that takes in the contact and impulse, pass for Box2D. And we'll
actually send that to the PostSolve function in our contact, giving it the 2
bodies for the fixtures that are touching. Now Box2D operates in a different
environment than we do. That is that it operates in fixtures that are
colliding, and we have to go then fetch the body object that we're using. Once
we've set all of our callback handlers that we want, we actually can call
world.SetContactListener and pass in the listener object. This will effectively
bake in all of our contact objects into the world, so that any time we get
these collision objects, we'll get collision callbacks.